you've done a horror film mothman
prophecies done political thriller
Arlington Road this is a little out of
the ballpark for you yeah the last
picture I made that probably nobody ever
saw was the darkest movie ever made
called I melt with you so after that and
I needed to come back the other way so I
consciously just wanted to do something
that was more lighthearted and I love
the story I think I've got a lot of
different colors but I think thrillers
are probably my favorite to do but they
stopped making mid-range you know studio
thrillers cuz they made stop making
those great ashley judd movies you know
and but anyway this is a script i really
liked and it was fun to do how did it
come to you because we hear so much
about oh there aren't any great roles
for women and here are roles for women
of every generation you know every
iteration the writer stewart think i was
doing a commercial with him a few years
ago and he said he had an idea for a
movie and he told me the idea so that's
a good one you should write it and he
wrote it and it was kind of needed a
little bit of work and within about six
months we did a draft and got it
together and then went to the usual
process of taking about a year to get
the actors cast we went to shirley first
actually and they wouldn't read it
without an offer so you know you're in
that chicken in the egg indie movie
where you need the actor to trigger that
but so after taking a swing and a few
other people we went back and she said
yes and then went to Amanda she took a
swing in a couple of people you know as
she could do that didn't work out but we
quickly went to Amanda who I always
loved and what's the two of them collect
I think it took about six months for
married kind of through combination of
foreign sales and a little bit of this
and a little bit of that get the bread
together who was about four and a half
million well once you had it CAF and
when she started shooting did the story
change at all because of who you had
doing this you know the basic story did
not change I mean surely brought a lot
to the table she improv
you know the major radio station stuff
where she said you know how don't have a
nice day of a day that means something
that was all her that was class where we
had an hour at the end of the day and I
said I know we're going to want her to
be seen as a DJ that's where we shot her
and with little girls just kind of
messing about so in you know in those 25
days shoots you still do have some
little pockets of time where they could
try some stuff to that that kind of
evolved a little bit but mostly we were
able to shoot the home pretty much the
whole movie in sequence which is really
good and Shirley had never really done
that before or she said she hadn't so
for her to do like kind of an indie
movie 25 days is tough and she's in most
of the movie that was really beneficial
those really i think maybe some of the
stuff at the end of the day to literally
like her dying was like the next the
last day and that's what i love working
like that and i'd made my master last
movie like that too so that's a such a
blessing to be able to get that
opportunity so now what do you learn
from your actors when you come away from
a project like this because you must
build on it with every new undertaking
well surely was a real trip we were all
waiting for that noun there was like at
the beginning at a point she said she
had never worked with a direct man that
was very stream of consciousness and
like forget to marks I don't care about
rehearsal just do it I don't want to
rehearse it let's see what happens so
that was new to her she had never really
worked like that before sometimes she
would yell at me and said director like
a hologram other times she's like okay I
got it you know but she as long as you
had an idea she liked to explore so she
liked to kind of do that and one time
she said okay just was at the beginning
where she's drinking the wine the pills
she was just telling me exactly what to
do he can types it's non dialogue so
tell me exactly what to do so I tell her
next take I'm telling her again she'll
stop telling me what to do
so she does it we do the third take and
like at this point I'm like I'm making
so we design and I don't say anything to
her right and she's like are you gonna
tell me what to do so it's kind of like
this I feel like we just got to give him
the same page tell me I'll do it as Jeff
Bridges who saved do the bad version
like just show me what to do and so once
we worked out that rhythm then that took
like a couple days then she was just off
and just sit there and watch her she
loved like digital she loved rolling and
continuing to roll and I said I want to
run four in a row she loved that you
could tell when she wanted to stop
sometimes she wanted to keep going and
Amanda when to stop and sometimes they
get lost in not a good way sometimes
they get lost in a good way and you want
them to fight through it because they
might discover something actually
unprepared in it and a lot of that there
was a lot of that in Shirley thank you
for bringing her to us in this iteration
please thank your talent and reflectors